what's up fellow Geeks today we have the
Samsung Galaxy A14 with us and it's the
most affordable Galaxy phone in
Samsung's lineup with the battery
they're saying can last two days we are
going to be putting this through the
gaming Gauntlet Genji impact pubg mobile
Call of Duty mobile and Diablo Immortal
performance wise the Samsung Galaxy A14
that we are using has an Octa Core 6
gigs of RAM 128 gigs of storage and a
Mali g57 mc2 for its GPU all this plays
out on a 6.6 inch full HD Plus display
with a Max refresh rate of 90 Hertz and
it's powered by a 5 000 milliamp hour
battery so before we run the test let's
do a baseline of the temperatures of the
front and the back of the phone
so
we are looking at about 28 degrees in
the front so far
let's check that again
27.
28 28.4 the bottom is around 3231
interesting and on the back
30 degrees down here
civil 30 degrees on the back interesting
all right oh 33 on the top oh that's is
it 32 here
oh yeah it is it's going to be so with
that let's just get into the first game
Kenshin alright so we are currently a
monster let's just open up the settings
real quick and see what we have going on
and see we set everything to the highest
we are pushing this phone quite a bit
actually uh 60 FPS everything has been
turned on so we are covered in this
section not the most powerful phone but
it definitely does work so far let's
just move around a little bit on here
before you head over to Inner Zuma and
as you can see it actually plays out all
right ish
a couple of a lot of area drops actually
so be quite interesting to see how this
plays out in the comment sections so
let's just head over to Inazuma all
right so before we do the walkthrough in
Azuma let's just look at how our
characters look like uh we have kamisato
over here and let's just
zoom in and see how she looks like she
looks really good in this actually
honestly there isn't much of an issue
when it comes to how good the game looks
like on the phone this HD Plus display
is actually doing the work right now
obviously you know it's a lot of female
jobs here and there as you can see you
can see move around
but it looks really good still there is
some sort of stability
but other than that
you know you just expect a lot of
hearing jobs but she looks great and so
does a scenery around her as well the
physics of all of these sakuras falling
and let's just go down and see how this
fast like oh when we go into the town
and let's just keep moving and just try
oh that you can see
there is a lot of very jobs going on
right now a lot of things aren't really
loading up property ish if you can tell
all right I think you guys get the idea
that you know this phone really can't
handle the highest I've said things
again this everything set on high right
now and I think if you set the settings
to like say lower medium I think it will
be able to handle it much better and
smoother than what it is right now so
let's just move on to some exploration
and maybe some combat outside in the
field
all right so let's just go out and
explore a little bit if we can get into
fight we should get into a fight because
I really I really do want to get into a
fight and let's see oh never mind we got
one
oh
boy
oh boy look at that
all right let's ulti real quick let's
see how it looks like
so as you can see the phone really
doesn't do it it's all these and special
attacks any kind of Justice on the high
set things without it breaking frames by
like what 7 FPS 6 FPS from what I'm
seeing right now and let's just get into
another fight here real quick and just
yeah look at that but what I will say
about the phone so far is that it has a
really good size you have a lot of
really slip with your hands around so
that's great
as you can see
not the smoothest
I can't really learn a lot of hits
because
I can't exactly see where I'm going half
the time
[Music]
all right and that's one fight and as
you can see you know it has been
breaking out a lot
so let's see how it fares in the spiral
Abyss
so as you can see the phone really
doesn't do the game that much Justice on
the so as you can see the phone really
doesn't do the game any kind of adjust
this on the highest of settings and I
really recommend you guys if you are
planning on getting this phone
stick to the medium or lows this is
quite difficult to play with let's go to
the spiral bits
all right so before we head into the
abyss let's just check temperatures real
quick it is heating up a little bit so
let's just check it out
38 degrees it's actually doing a lot
better than I expect
much better than the black stock 5
actually even for Budget phone wow yeah
39 38
not doing two three okay doing okay
actually wow
so it does get heat management right
that is surprising
all right 41 40 yeah that's all that's
quite surprising actually wow okay oh
all right Alti
all right
oh
yeah that is very very
that's a lot of Premium jobs right there
oh get away
[Applause]
well actually you know what on these
spiral bits the phone is actually
handling itself pretty well so far a lot
better than I expected
it's not as laggy as open world actually
[Music]
all right okay let's just go for one
more round and see how this performs
before we hit the final temperature
check and closing on genshin uh
yes
oh boy that was bad
[Music]
nice
guy
okay now on the other side
so so far performance it's surprisingly
it surprisingly got better compared to
the open world I think it's because of
the open world and the rain doing and
whatnot but Abyss why it's actually
doing pretty okay
[Applause]
can I really get the timing right on
this thing
it's actually really hard to throw this
much lag and also I've I have a terrible
teams that's what comes to competition
oh boy
everyone was there and okay Frank got
them all oh okay that's okay that's a
lot all right so that's it final
temperature check and let's see what
where we're at right now 92 percent
eight percent down from the initial
hundred
temperature wise we are at 39 degrees
yeah that's understandable 38 degrees 36
it's not even hitting 40 right now
actually it has gone down a little bit
let's check the back
and yeah it's 40 at the back
here 41 almost 42 I think nothing else
and let's see further down 35
it's barely faulty in this region so
yeah A14 handles handles this up pretty
well when it comes to your business but
I think with open areas obviously with
rendering and everything you guys are
better off playing Genji on the lower on
medium graphical settings so with that
yes
right so with that let's move on to the
next game
pubg mobile all right so we're in pubg
right now let's check the settings and
so far it looks pretty smooth I guess
and I hope it stays that way let's go
into the settings real quick okay so
let's do a temperature check real quick
before we head into
the game
37 degrees it has gone down a little bit
we just finished playing Genji impact so
it has gone down a bit from just now
from 41 years 40 degrees to about 37
inch that's all right
in my books 35s in this side and the
back
we are currently at 39 degrees on the
top half and it's good on the bottom it
gets progressively lower so yeah it's
actually doing pretty much fine right
now it's comfortable to touch all right
so we're in the settings right now I
don't think we can go higher than HD
yeah as you can see Ultra HD yeah and
yeah definitely not UHD
and uh three minutes on high style is on
classic right now and the a-listing
obviously four times still not there but
two times it's there and shadows enabled
everything is on so basically this is
the highest we can go with the A14 so
with that let's just get into the game
and see how this works out it's handling
itself pretty all right a couple of
three drops here and there again we are
playing on whatever highest I think we
can with the A14
good for you so let's just see how the
game runs
and this C130 is looking good look at
that
actually it's actually performing a lot
better in Kenshin
so far actually is performing a lot
better engaging so far I mean that's
pretty much off the bat law
okay so off the bat it is performing a
lot better than the engine so far let's
see where our guy wants to go
where do you want to go
you can go to the Sania if you want
yeah
I don't know if you want to drop down
okay oh he does want to drop down Okay
cool so we'll see how this pans out but
while we are here we might also talk
about how comfortable the phone is so
far and I'll say that it has a very good
size and I mean I have huge hands again
so you know my pinky still has somewhere
to go ish at the bottom and the top
feels all right it's just that the power
the volume buttons over here so it will
get in the real things but other than
that this thing is fine it even has a
headphone jack at the bottom if you guys
want to put headphones there of course
you know it will obstruct some stuff
here it will help shock your hand plate
on here so just go through wireless
earbuds for audio and let's just make
our drop
squat that's really close to us let's
just hit down here
all right we are on the ground let's
keep moving
okay
can I get things quick enough I can I
guess
so far
everything's working out fine picked it
up picked it up
obviously you have a much better time
playing pubg mobile because you know
it's not graphically intensive as
compared to game channel impact but you
know it's
it's still pretty good for the E4 team
so far even at its price especially at
its price point this thing is actually
handling games pretty well so far
besides Kenshin but again we are playing
everything on the highest graphical set
things that the games allow the hardware
to so with all this considered it's
actually doing pretty well
all right so far so good
oh where did those shots come from
those were very close watch
watch one second floor okay
let's head in and try to get this guy
is that green
oh green is down and
oh green it's dead oh man that's bad
it's bad right yeah that's bad
let's just try to hunt down those guys
try to get some Revenge room
I believe he's in there
restaurant over there try to get a jump
on these guys
do they engage with another Squad
I'll see you
that's just one guy for now
here they're on me right now but let's
just double back
oh boy
all right he's down
nice
so yeah combat so far like I said you
know if you guys can properly adjust and
assign you about this property I guess
you guys will have a much better time
than I am I'm running the default right
now someone's running up on me
I believe you know oh yeah
I need a scope
so uh I think they go to the plant
and I'm dead now
none of my guys obviously going to come
and save me but for what it's worth pubg
mobile has been pretty fun so far the
A14 and let's do a temperature check
real quick
um it is 30 degrees oh so it has kind of
stayed at the original temperature that
we had close to the original temperature
we had after
we got off from genshin so let's just
see this and oh 34ish all right okay not
too bad I'm gonna check the back
okay yeah I just keep doing not too bad
all right let's check the bathroom real
quick sorry 35 34. okay we're doing
pretty right we're doing all right the
5G mobile is doing pretty well so far we
have everything on the highest set
things that we are able to get out of
this spawn and you know the point allows
us to so with that let's move to our
next game Call of Duty mobile but before
that here's a message from our sponsor
this video is brought to you by MSI meet
the summit E6 and flip featuring the
latest 12th gen Intel Core i7 processor
RTX 30 series graphics and a 16 inch
Quad HD Plus touchscreen panel with a
360 degree hinge it lets you unleash
maximum productivity with up to 11 hours
of battery life and just 2 kilograms the
summit e16 flip offers unprecedented
performance and functionality allowing
you to work and play anywhere anytime
all right so right off pubg mobile we
are in Call of Duty mobile right now
let's check them pictures real quick
before we get in we are currently at 86
86 right there so let's check the
pictures real quick before we head into
a match
38 degrees down here 37-ish 36. and 35
is 34.
not too bad let's check the back
all right 34 38 we're actually doing
pretty all right top five 239ish
somewhere around there
but other than that we are doing fine
all right
so let's go into settings
right graphics
and we are okay we only have medium
enabled photography quality uh let's
check high top frame rate
everything else that's going multiplayer
a lot of things are not really available
to us
yeah this is all we have to work with
because of this
set thing on here we only have medium so
with that in mind let's just get into a
match let's actually do a Shader preload
all right so let's actually do the
Shader preload and let's see if we can
get better results out of this phone and
it's graphical quality
all right we're done with the Shaded
pre-loading and let's just get into a
match I mean this is just mediumship
thing but this is the best you can do
for this phone
all right let's scoot up
on no I can't get him okay never mind
we'll just Resort two running
yay so far doing pretty all right as a
team I'm not doing well as a player and
I'm not really contributing much of the
team but this is doing great to me okay
let's just get her on the back
but so far it plays creepy all right
oh boy
there we go the phone's doing great like
for what it's worth it's actually
performing pretty well but I'm just
completely well oh God
but that's it I'm being bad
boys performing well though it's very
smooth
High FPS rate nothing no three drops
whatsoever nothing yet nothing of the
sword yet but
come on
there we go okay so with genjin and pubg
mobile obviously you have almost all of
the options available for you almost all
of them
oh boy but with Call of Duty we kind of
locked it up for you so
they're telling you that you can only
play at this range which is kind of
helpful for some of you out there but
for the most part I mean it's kind of
restricting because I think this one can
push Call of Duty a little bit more
competitive to the other three games
or even pubg actually yeah this one can
actually definitely push pubg and Call
of Duty a lot more hotels graphical
settings and equality
the bills merely extra for you guys
come on
where you at
I don't know
nice
all right you're doing okay very fine no
grenade over there
that's it for call duty and I feel that
the devs shouldn't have put the
additional graphical settings behind the
wall like they did with Pub G but it is
what it is so let's do a final
temperature check before we head out to
Diablo Moto
and on the front we're running at about
37 it has actually gone down from when
we left off a pubg
and yeah it's gonna quite a lot actually
wow okay let's check the back
33.6
and the bottom half and then 34 35
at the top wow okay doing pretty well
actually so with that let's move on to
our last game Diablo Immortal all right
we've let the camera rest for a little
bit it's been overheating quite a lot so
right now we are currently at 80 battery
we run we're going to be running through
four games after three games we're down
by 20 so let's do a temperature check
before we get into Diablo immortal
31 degrees it has cooled down quite a
bit also given that you know we've given
time for our camera to cool down as well
32 degrees let's check the back
30 years degrees and then yeah looks
pretty much my foam throughout the phone
so with that let's enter Diablo immortal
right here
all right there she is looking pretty
good I'd say so myself so far
I have no idea what graphical settings
we are on so let's just enter the world
and see what's up we are in Westmont
right now so let's just check our
settings real quick
set things
graphics and okay frame rate 60 not
available for this device we're gonna be
playing at 30 FPS throughout let's go
Ultra
not supported on the A14 Heidel highest
all right let's do some image opening
because why not and then quality section
hi hi and everything else you said on
high because we can all right so with
that
everything should be set and ready to go
now we have to see how it fares like in
an area with a lot of mobs so let's go
and run a rift
oh there we go there we go
here we go
so far is handling itself pretty well
down nearly huge favorite drops
as far as I can tell with all the
effects going on
it's all right doing okay it's doing
okay
Abomination over there
Hulk sorry
all right let's keep moving
[Applause]
all right I need to find a way oh it's
this way okay here we go get the Golem
out again
yeah so when I activate a lot a couple
skills at the same time it will actually
drop a little bit because in terms of
the FPS
all right let's go down
let's see
especially with the escaping archers and
everything else at the same time
but that's also kind of a given
but for what it's worth and it's current
specs that the phone has but you're
doing pretty well
in my opinion at least
now it's super free to look at it but
it's all good
for now
I need that I need to be honest like
there hasn't been any significant damage
drops whatsoever
and your last few months to kill before
we get to the Victorian
to find those guys because a lot
and get everything up
all right you got the roof Guardian
somewhere on the other side
okay
whatever
man
get out of the way
position our arches here and he's done
oh boy
I mean that's as smooth as we can go at
the highest graphical settings again we
are playing at the highest graphical
setting so I can't really complain too
much
especially with the current specs that
the phone has but other than that I
think it handled the rift pretty well
okay so with the rift over let's do some
exploration in my favorite place
the actual symmetry
it is dropping quite a lot especially
other players around us
so
yes
oh boy that's pretty bad
oh wow okay okay we are playing the
highest settings of things just really
really just keep that in mind if you
guys created on the recommended set of
things you would have more much more
smoother experience I am doing this for
science right now
oh yeah look at that oh
great
you're the one thing I forgot to do
can't be detect after the rift so let's
just do that real quick
we are currently at 36 degrees honestly
it hasn't really
gone out that much of the temperature
I'm quite surprised on this front all
right 37 on the left side which is
probably where the chips are at the back
in the top half obviously
so here let's check the back
running at 39 40 but honestly it doesn't
feel like 39 or 40 so really props the
Samsung for doing this they've improved
heat Management on their phones quite a
bit
all right let's get back
[Applause]
okay oh boy look at that
yeah that is quite a bit
anyway it would just be exploring a bit
more before we conclude our Diablo
Immortal run and go to our final
conclusions of the video all right so
with that that will be the end of Diablo
Immortal let's just walk around town as
we talk about it so Diablo motto you
know obviously they've also put some
obviously this phone can run any of the
higher specs and I think for good reason
also I mean in comparison to pubg and
the rest but we talk about that later on
but for what it's worth this phone can
handle Diablo motto if it was set to the
recommended set of things we are pushing
it quite a bit by putting all the high
set things and everything as you can see
the frame rate is dropping quite a fair
bit just running through as much right
now and yeah that's about it and let's
do a final temperature check we've
played for about a good 15 minutes and
we are currently at 75 we start over 100
so after four games we have gone down by
25 let's do a quick temperature check
and 38 degrees it actually has gone down
from the time we were
in the
okay
all right all right let's do a
temperature check real quick
uh currently at 38.2 it has gone down a
little bit if I'm not wrong or it has
gone up a little bit
uh let's see 33 35 on this side let's
check back
and
it's 40 degrees yeah it has gone up but
like I said again okay it actually
hasn't gone up it has sustained it has
stayed at 40 degrees maybe it has gone
up by a little bit but honestly I can't
feel the difference and let's see the
board film here 34-ish 35-ish 33 ish
yeah it's doing pretty well I am quite
impressed with
Samsung's I am quite impressed with
Samsung store management and with that
let's just head on to the final
conclusion I am quite surprised by how
the Samsung Galaxy A14 has handled
itself despite being in the wallet
friendly lineup it really has better
thermal management than some Flagship
and gaming phones out there even though
games have limited their graphical
settings due to the phone's Hardware I
feel that the A14 could push certain
games more such as Call of Duty and pubg
let's do with genjin obviously but for
how much the phone is worth on top of
great thermal management and its battery
managing itself well over the course of
four intensive games in a row the Galaxy
e14 is a really enjoyable phone to Game
On when played at its recommended set
things No Frills just gaming if you have
any questions about the Samsung Galaxy
A14 leave them in the comment section
below and I'll do my best to get to them
keep up to date with us by following all
of our socials for the latest news right
here and if you like this video consider
hitting the like And subscribe button it
goes a long way if you want to see more
stuff from us check this out up
[Music]
foreign